hey you guys flickers of fear my movie
review show
now we're going back to
dario argento i think the last argento
movie i did was maybe opera
and i think i did phenomena before that
um i kind of feel like and i might have
got into this a little bit on my opera
review where i feel like a lot of people
think that opera which came out in i
think 1987
was kind of like the last of his really
really good films and then like the ones
after that were just very
bad or just kind of like hit or miss uh
to a large extent i would agree with
that although
i'm willing to go to bat for stendahl
syndrome which i believe came out in
1996
and sleepless has its fans as well
although i will admit that i've only
seen that once and it was a really
really long time ago and i don't really
remember hardly anything about it so
uh so i can't really say so i'm gonna
have to like watch that again at some
point because that's another one that
people you know say is kind of like a
high point of his later career
this movie
is re this is one is very strange this
is trauma from 1993.
now
back in the 90s i saw this movie a lot
of times uh because i used to have it on
dvd
and i always kind of had like a soft
spot for it
and but the thing about it is that it
really didn't i guess it didn't leave a
lasting impression because even though i
saw it a bunch of times back then i sort
of like forgot about it
and then i was scrolling through shutter
recently and they had added it and i was
like oh yeah i kind of remember that but
i couldn't like remember exactly what it
was about
um i guess that shutter put it up
because vinegar syndrome the company
just put out like a nice uh blu-ray of
it i believe uh right around christmas
time i think of 2021
so shutter was showing it and i was like
oh what the hell i'm gonna rewatch that
and it's funny because like the second i
started watching it like pretty much it
all came back to me because as i said
i've seen this movie lots and lots of
times now i will say if you're new to
dario argento's uh films
this is really not the one to start with
this is i mean i actually kind of have a
lot of affection for this movie but i do
know a lot of dario argento fans who
absolutely hate it or think it's
terrible and it's just like a mess and i
can see where they're coming from with
it but like i said i kind of i don't
know there's a lot about this movie that
i actually kind of really like but you
know your mileage may vary i'm just
saying that don't ever make this like
your first dario argento movie because
in a lot of ways it's a lot different
than most of his regular fare and even
though i do think that it's
unfairly maligned a lot of times i can
see that there are a lot of problems
with it even though i i kind of like it
and i like enjoyed revisiting it and
remembering it you know because i'd seen
it so many times back in the day
so now interestingly this was one of
only two movies that dario made in the
united states he's italian obviously if
you didn't know
uh the first one being uh two evil eyes
which was actually like a two it wasn't
an anthology necessarily but it was two
stories two edgar allen poe stories uh
he did the black cat and uh george a
romero directed the other half of the
movie which i think was facts in the
case of m valdemar
and so that came out in 1990
and that was made in the united states
so i don't think it did all that well i
remember kind of liking that movie but
again i haven't seen it in a while but i
guess it did well enough for the
american production company to give
daario license to do a full-length movie
in the united states and that ended up
being trauma which came out in 1993.
so this film was shot in minneapolis
and to be honest i kind of think that
maybe that's one of the things that
i don't want to say like it works
against it but i think the thing that a
lot of people like about dario argento's
work in general especially his uh his
older stuff
is that kind of
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
italy but just that kind of like really
gothic baroque sort of sensibility like
the whole aesthetic of it and this one
because it was kind of shot just in a
midwestern city it doesn't really have
any of that really cool style to it that
a lot of people look for in their dario
argento movies so know that going in
this was shot in minneapolis it's
nothing like visually it's kind of like
nothing special there are kind of like a
few cool shots in there and a few hints
of like his old kind of like stylish
sort of thing but
it's really not so much concerned about
visuals this is actually kind of more
a character piece and it is a giallo um
but
it has i mean it has a lot of gel
elements to it i guess i would call it a
giallo technically it is um but there's
a lot of other stuff going on in it as
well
this was actually the first time that he
had uh directed his daughter asia she i
believe
uh was 17 or 18 i hope she was 18
but this movie was filmed which i'll get
into why in a minute although the
character she's playing in the movie is
supposed to be 16.
now i love aziyah argento i do but she's
very young in this and she seems i don't
know like her acting is not great but i
don't know there's there's something
about it that's kind of endearing though
i guess in a way and she's playing a
romanian character so she has like a
little bit of an accent but it's not
like distracting or anything like that
because she actually has a very thick
italian accent anyways so i'm used to
uh her voice so this is like not
dubbed like a lot of italian movies are
so you do actually get to hear people's
voices which is nice
uh this also has some kind of
i i don't know like i i would call them
sort of like glorified cameos i guess uh
by some very heavy hitters especially in
the horror genre you got piper laurie
and they're playing uh ozzy argento's
mom and you also have brad dorff who
you know i i [ __ ] love brad dorf i
wish he'd been in this more
um he's probably only in like maybe two
scenes uh but his death scene is like
pretty epic so i mean the special
effects are bad but uh but it's pretty
epic like how it happens i just wish
he'd kind of been utilized a little bit
more uh frederick forrest is in this as
well
and so you're gonna see like a lot of
familiar faces christopher rydell who
plays sort of like the male protagonist
uh i've i know i've seen him and other
stuff but i can't remember what i forgot
to like look it up because i was like ah
that guy's like so familiar but i can't
remember like where else i've seen him
before
so the story of this oh i will say too
that
i had forgotten
until i started re-watching the movie
i started re-watching the movie and then
um there's a scene near the very
beginning like when the killer first
strikes
and there is a tokay gekko
in the scene
and at that point i remembered very
vividly i said oh [ __ ] this movie has a
scene where one of those lizards gets
squished it's not real i hope it better
not be [ __ ] real i mean this was shot
in the united states in the 90s and i
don't think you could get away with like
squishing a lizard like on like
especially one as big as a gecko
but i remember because i used to have a
pet uh toki gekko for for a while and i
think they're super cute
and so i remember that really really
upsetting me so i will admit when i
rewatched this movie on shutter
yesterday i when it got to that scene
that i knew that was going to happen i
skipped over
because it's like even if it's fake i
don't want to see it it was just too
upsetting i'm just getting to like it's
funny because this movie it's like
people like people get beheaded like all
day long and i'm just like don't care
but it's like you heard a lizard and i'm
just like no thank you i just had to
skip over it like you know how i am but
i did used to have one of those as a pet
and it's like i think they're super cute
and it's just i that scene just like
bothers me and i remembered like where
the scene fell like in and i was just
like oh yeah that's where this is and
it's not
it's not like super important to the
plot i mean it's just in there to be
gross or whatever so
you know it's not like you miss anything
and i remembered what happened in that
scene anyway like once i started
watching it
okay so what happens in this movie
you have near the very beginning well at
the very beginning you kind of have sort
of like a weird like cold open thing
with like this little french revolution
little puppet show type situation which
will make more sense later on but
basically you have this opening scene
where this woman who you're led to
presume i think she's a chiropractor
and uh she has somebody come into her
office and it's you're seeing things
from the killer's point of view so she's
like uh oh yeah you're like a new
patient or whatever and uh she's the one
that has the toki geckos in the in her
like office like in a little cage she
has two of them and that's how the
killer ends up getting them and there's
that whole thing so uh so she's like oh
yeah you're a new patient and you know
and then like she's kind of looking at
the person and she's like you kind of
look familiar like have i seen you
somewhere before at which point uh the
killer because that's who this is takes
out this little device
which is essentially
it's like a handheld mechanized garat i
guess it's like what it's like this
little
thing like that was like a little handle
and it's got like a wire like piano wire
or something and you loop it around a
person's head and then turn on the the
switch and it pulls the thing and
basically squinches your head off which
handy um
they don't really they don't really sell
that on qvc or that i know of i mean you
know what i mean so uh fun fact tom
savini did the uh did the effects for
this and he actually came up with that
tool and called it the new somatic which
i thought was very funny but that is the
uh the killer's weapon of choice is just
this head squinting
machine so a lot of beheadings in this
uh and there's a reason for it and we'll
get into that later
so that's kind of your opening scene uh
you know so there's the heads just
laying there and
whatever
now a couple days after that we have our
main male protagonist whose name is
david he's played by christopher rydell
he's just driving down the street
minding his own beeswax and he sees this
skinny girl like this dark-haired girl
and she looks like she's gonna jump off
the bridge that he's driving over
so obviously he's like alarmed and so he
pulls over to like to help her and this
is uh aura she is uh again like supposed
to be 16 years old which like i said
we'll get into that a little bit because
it gets a little creepy
um so i'm just gonna like warn you
but yeah so
she's trying to kill herself and he's
like no no you don't want to do that
so she seems kind of like out of it and
he takes her to uh like a diner and
tries to get her to eat she doesn't want
to and then they kind of have like this
little argument so she eats a piece of
bread and then she goes in the bathroom
and pukes and then like escapes like
runs out the back of the restaurant or
whatever
now uh what ends up happening is that
while she's running down the street like
these two guys in suits like come up to
her and they grab her and they're like
yeah we're taking you back to wherever
because you find out that she actually
escaped from
a psychiatric hospital called the
faraday clinic
so they don't actually end up taking her
back to the hospital at first they
actually take her back to her parents
house at which point david the guy who
rescued her finds out that she stole his
wallet which will come in which will
kind of like uh come into play later on
so they take her back to her house and
she lives kind of in this really nice
house now her parents are kind of weird
uh her mom is played by piper laurie and
uh so they are having a seance because
apparently her mom is a medium
and honestly i think the seance scene is
probably my favorite i love seances in
movies i don't know why it's just like a
thing that i have i really do like the
seance in this one because it is
actually kind of creepy where piper
laurie's character whose name is uh
adriana i think she's kind of like
contacting the spirits or whatever and
this spirit starts
you're led to assume that this is the
spirit of the woman the chiropractor
that was beheaded at the beginning of
the movie because she says
something like uh you know my head he
took my head um you know the killer is
present
so and everybody's like wigging out
obviously because you know this medium
is saying that the killer is here
somewhere and that it's that he's like
taking people's heads and that's like
not good
so at that point
um for whatever like i said there's kind
of mass panic everybody at the seance is
flipping out and then the mom and the
dad like aura's mom and dad like run out
into because i think the dad runs out
first and the or the mom runs out and
then the dad chases her or whatever they
go out into the rain and it's like this
big yard and everything then alright
argento's character she runs out after
them at which point she sees
through the bushes she sees like what
she thinks is her mom who's been
beheaded and then she sees what she
thinks is the killer holding up her mom
and her dad's head like in front of his
face and she like obviously flips out
because now both her parents are dead
and [ __ ] like that
so uh at this point she has this doctor
that comes there dr judd who is
apparently taking care of her at the
faraday clinic
and then the cops come
and she's kind of like she says she
didn't see anything um she says you know
they the killer was like holding these
heads up in front of the face and i
didn't see who it was and she manages to
uh elude the police and then because she
stole david's wallet she looks at his
driver's license and basically uh goes
and finds him like at his job now he is
he works at like a tv station and i
think that he's like a he's like a
storyboard artist or like a sketch
artist because he's doing like sketches
so i guess like back in 1993
when they were doing uh you know news
broadcasts and stuff like that they had
he had to design like all the graphics
like in the background so that's kind of
what he does for a job
so uh so she finds him and like waits
outside of his thing and she's like i'm
sorry i stole your wallet i needed some
food so she gives it back to him and uh
she's basically like yeah both my
parents got murdered by this
you know killer that's going around and
like i said because of the chiropractor
being killed at the beginning and now
there's like a double murder so now
they're thinking oh it's a serial killer
and they start calling it predictably
the headhunter
now uh so there's that going on and
she's like look i don't have a place to
stay both my parents are dead now so he
said okay well you can come back and
stay at my uh apartment
now at this point we have like the
lizard scene and
how that even comes into it like i said
it's not hugely relevant to the plot but
there's this little kid named gabriel
who apparently lives next door
to the killer like that he doesn't know
that obviously
but he's freaking out like at night
because the killer has taken the
chiropractor's head just to be like for
shits and giggles i guess and has put it
in the window like looking out
at this kid's bedroom widow so like when
he looks out he just sees somebody
looking at him that doesn't ever move
and it's like wigging him out a little
bit so there's that so gabriel is the
kid that lives next door and he's the
one that actually
gets curious and sneaks over to the
killer's house and finds he sees the
lizard like killing a butterfly and then
like he goes in there and finds the head
squinching tool and all this other stuff
and well he's like really scared because
he finds like all this murdery [ __ ] and
i think he finds the head too and he's
holding one of the lizards and like
squishes it and it's like it really
really upsets me and i can't like even
talking about it makes me upset but yeah
so that's where that came into it so i
was just like nope and i just like
skipped right past that point but you
know i knew what happened did it so it
was okay
so uh so at that point we're back with
uh david and aara she is uh obviously
having some problems like i said not
only were her parents both apparently uh
decapitated right in front of her
essentially uh but she escaped from a
psychiatric clinic and you uh you find
out that what is wrong with her actually
is that she is anorexic although i kind
of feel like they did okay with the
anorexia on this one and i'm gonna get
why this is like so about anorexia in a
bit but she also has like bulimic traits
too because at this point like david
comes out the kitchen and there's like
food all over the place because it looks
like she binged and then she's like
puking in the bathroom
so the next day he like tells one of his
workmates about it and the workmate who
says that he's uh been watching oprah
and [ __ ] so he knows all about anorexia
and so he goes off on this big thing
about like what it is which like i said
is
mostly accurate but has some like other
weird [ __ ] in there too that's not super
accurate like i had a family member that
had anorexia so i know a little bit
about it but some of the stuff in there
was was fine uh some of the
psychological stuff was a little iffy
but it wasn't too bad
now uh so at this point david
who up to this point because he's been
letting ours stay at his house because
like i said he feels bad for her he
saved her from competing suicide she's
obviously got problems and uh you know
he wants to help her uh she doesn't have
any else place else to stay so he's been
letting her stay at this uh at his
apartment but he also has i wouldn't
call her a girlfriend but she he's kind
of like i don't know a [ __ ] buddy like a
friend with benefits something like that
so it's this woman named grace that he
works with she's like um like an on-air
personnel like a newscaster and uh she's
a stone cold [ __ ] also but uh you know
she you find that out later on but uh
yeah so but he's like sometimes calls
her up like for booty calls or whatever
so she calls him and she's kind of like
um you know she wants to come over one
night but he's like now i have this you
know this this kid here and he's very
like adamant about saying she's just a
kid she's just a kid like i said she's
16. she was older than that uh you know
that actually ozzy argento was older
than that i've seen 17 i've also seen 18
but she's playing a 16 year old his
character i don't think they specify how
old he's supposed to be but he's clearly
older than college because he has like a
job
so i was imagining he looks about 28 or
29 and i think that the actor i think
the actor playing him i think there was
a 12-year age gap um because i think he
might have been 30 or 29 or 30 like when
he was filming this so it's a little
weird so anyway i'm just going to get
getting into that uh so in an effort to
prove to grace
that
you know this
this child this 16 year old is not
actually his
new girlfriend he's like yeah she's here
but it's fine you can totally come over
and we can [ __ ] or whatever
so
so grace comes over and they're [ __ ]
and then and then ozzy or aura she comes
out and sees them and it's just kind of
like nope uh because there's a thing in
it where anorexics are like
uh afraid of sex and stuff which isn't
entirely inaccurate they do have a thing
where they they don't really want to
grow up uh so they're they want their
bodies to be like still stay like child
bodies and there is like a weird scene
where
um david like walks past the bathroom
and sees aura and she has a thing like
over her boobs like flattening her boobs
and then like she takes it off so you
can see like
sazier argento's boobs and at which
point you have to think well she's only
17 or 18 years old and her dad directed
this movie but
we've i don't know i kind of feel like
i've talked about that before because
daario and asia i'm not really sure what
their like uh relationship is like but
he does like some really weird [ __ ]
[ __ ] to her in his movies like in the
stendhal syndrome she's like brutally
raped like a bunch of times like in that
movie and it's just like
it's just i don't know it's very weird
but like i said maybe it's not that
weird to them
but yeah so uh so yeah so you do
actually get to see her boobs in this
even though she's i don't think she's
actually the actress is actually
underage but it is kind of weird to have
your dad maybe he wasn't on set i don't
know but it is kind of weird to have
your dad direct in a movie and be like
yeah it's titties what i don't know it's
just very very strange but yeah so uh so
anyway she runs off uh when she sees um
david and grace having sex and then
david is just tells grace to get the
[ __ ] out and then he runs after her and
even though david has been like adamant
as i said by saying this is just a kid
just a kid but as soon as like she he
catches up with her they start like
hugging and making out and obviously now
they're
a thing like so now he actually does
have
a 16 year old girlfriend because they do
they don't have sex but they kind of
tried to i guess because she says the
next morning she's like oh i'm sorry i
couldn't um you know because like i said
she still had that thing but so yeah
it's all a little bit i don't know i
guess it's all a little bit sketchy
[Laughter]
i was thinking about it earlier and i
was like well
it almost kind of seems like it's almost
like the same uh
the same age dynamic as you saw in the
much beloved 1987 movie dirty dancing
because i think that jennifer gray's
character was supposed to be 16 too in
that right and then like patrick
swayze's character was way older so i
guess you have a similar thing going on
here although
i'm not sure if jennifer gray the
actress uh was older like obviously she
was older than 16 but i don't know how
much older she was in this one like i
said um ozzy argento was only a year or
two older than her character was
supposed to be and i think that the
actor playing david was in his late 20s
or maybe he was 30. so it does seem like
a little bit weird uh especially because
he made so much of the fact of her being
a kid like the whole like first half of
the movie and then he's like oh never
mind we're like boyfriend girlfriend now
so i don't know it's just really weird
but yeah so
because grace uh the
his [ __ ] buddy that worked at the news
station with him because she was pissed
off about being like apparently thrown
over for this younger model
she actually reported aura
to the faraday clinic and uh so when he
comes home one day
she's like yeah they came and got her
because she's supposed to go back to
clinic
so they take her back there and uh dr
judd her doctor is like trying to like
hypnotize her or he actually doesn't
hypnotize her it gives her these weird
like
psychotropic like berries or something
like that that's supposed to be like
some kind of it's supposed to be like a
memory uh enhancer i guess and uh is
trying to get her to remember like what
happened the night of the murder so she
could like see the killer's face but it
doesn't really go all that well because
she doesn't remember who it is meanwhile
back at the station uh david and his
buddy have figured out that all of the
murders so far have occurred when it was
raining uh so there's that and then when
he finds out like i said that um that
aura has been uh taken back to the
faraday clinic so he goes there she had
stolen some keys so he actually is able
to bust her out
now at this point too they sort of like
get to the bottom of the of the mystery
and i don't know like i said this came
out in 1993 i'm not sure i entirely want
to spoil it but
the
much like in a lot of giallo movies um
the
the motive for the killer is something
that happened in the distant past and
all of the people that um are killed
even though they seem just like random
people actually all were involved in
something horrible back in the old days
that the killer is getting revenge for
so i'm not gonna spoil who it is because
like i said they just put this up on
shutter and i feel like maybe a lot of
people haven't seen it as i said if
you're into dario argento
then you should probably give it a watch
i feel like it's one of his more
forgotten ones but i will totally
understand if you're not really all that
into it because
it does have a lot of the aspects that
make dario argento stuff so appealing um
i do like the giallo aspect i like the
over-the-top
uh motivation of the killer actually the
motivation of the killer is actually
like pretty horrific like what ended up
happening back in the past is like
pretty [ __ ] up even though it's
improbable i really do like the head
squinching machine like the new somatic
thing like i think that's a pretty cool
uh little touch
and the but i will say that this has
like a lot of problems to it as well i
feel like the story is a little bit
convoluted it's not super hard to follow
but there is some stuff that probably
could have been excised it's not a
hugely long movie i think it's an hour
and 45 minutes it's a little bit long
for a horror movie but i didn't feel
like it dragged or anything like i was
pretty invested in it
um i kind of wish brad dorff had been in
it more um he gets killed by the way uh
by getting his head lopped off by an uh
an elevator descending and like i said
the green screen of his head screaming
and stuff like that is
again improbable the special effect
isn't that great but it's still pretty
entertaining i did like um the sort of
recurring motif of some of the heads
after they got cut off like still sort
of being able to talk for a second or
like move around because
i'm i'm like really weirded out by
decapitations um because it's always
been like a source of morbid fascination
for me like how long that you would know
that you had been beheaded like you know
even for 30 seconds that seems like a
really long time when you're just ahead
so the fact that he put like a couple
scenes in there where like the head got
cut off and was still kind of talking
and like looking around for a second
like always kind of like weirded me out
so there's that i will say too that even
though tom savini worked on this movie
and he was the one that came up with the
new somatic machine and all that kind of
stuff there's not as much gore in this
as you might imagine like you know
knowing those facts knowing this is a
dario argento movie knowing that tom
savini was the one that did the effects
and i don't know i think that tom savini
did do some more
uh kind of like egregious like gore
beheadings and stuff i mean the
beheadings are bloody but it's not as
over the top as some of uh you know
argento's earlier work was i don't think
it was uh to do with censorship or
anything like that i just think that
they did the gory scenes and then i
think daario wanted to step back from
that a little bit so he could
concentrate more on the mystery and the
suspense and the character building and
stuff like that rather than having all
this over-the-top gore i'm not entirely
sure that was the right decision because
like i said a lot of people do like to
watch his movies for that but
you know i respect if he wanted to go
like in a slightly different direction
with it i will say too that i did kind
of like
the fact that um that ozzy argento's
character
is anorexic and i do think they treat
that
uh pretty sensitively in this and
there's a reason for that it's because
ozzy argento's half sister so not daria
not uh daario's daughter but daria
nickelode's daughter from a previous
marriage before her and dario argento
got together because ozzya is
dario argento and daria nickelode's kid
so daria nickelode's other daughter she
had a daughter named anna
and anna had anorexia
and anna actually uh shows up in this
movie and that's why at the end like
over the credits where that last scene
is like there's that really really
skinny girl like dancing on the balcony
and it really doesn't have anything to
do with the rest of the movie so you'd
be forgiven for being like what the hell
that's the reason because that's anna
she had anorexia and that was where
dario argento kind of he was this was i
guess his way of like dealing with it or
working through it unfortunately uh anna
ended up dying not too long after this
movie came out not from anorexia she was
actually in a motorcycle accident i
believe that killed her so uh but yeah
so she's in this but that's the reason
that
that anorexia is like such a big
plot point in this even though i will
say ozzya looks very thin but she
doesn't look
anorexic you know what i mean in the
same way that her half-sister anna does
at the end who absolutely kind of does
look anorexic i have to say she's very
very skinny but yeah so like i said i
don't really i don't necessarily want to
poiso i don't want to like spoil who the
killer is even though as soon as i
because like i said i saw this movie a
bunch of times back in the 90s and then
i didn't see it again for a really long
time and then when i was re-watching it
like as soon as it came on like as soon
as that first couple scenes went by i
remembered like who the killer was and i
remembered i didn't remember exactly
what the motive was i sort of kind of
remembered
but i absolutely remember who the killer
was i don't know so i don't really want
to spoil it i don't i think you'll
probably be able to figure it out i'm
not really sure but so the story is a
little bit convoluted like i said it's
not as visually cool as a lot of
daario's other stuff it's not you know
the the setting of it isn't all that
interesting because it's just you know
nothing against minneapolis but it's not
a real like aesthetically visually like
beautiful looking city
in the way that a lot of his italian
settings and the other ones were
with all those baroque like backgrounds
and stuff this doesn't even have any of
that like you know crazy lighting or
anything like that i kind of feel like
he had gotten away from that like later
in the 80s anyways and but this is a lot
more
naturalistic
but it still has that over-the-top
element of
not quite believable there's even like
some kind of i don't even know if i'd
call it supernatural
aspects to it because you have the whole
thing at the with the seance at the
beginning and
what is presumably the ghost of this
chiropractor woman that gets killed at
the beginning who is
communicating with but the way that it
works out i mean that's not necessarily
a ghost i don't know but like i said
there's not supernatural stuff doesn't
happen like later on in the movie so
it's almost kind of like they introduce
that element but then it doesn't really
play into the movie all that much later
on so this is
grounded in reality like a lot of glows
are
even though it's very improbable the way
some of the murders take place you know
what i'm saying so there is still that
element of like that operatic that kind
of like unbelievable
sort of aspect to it reviews on this uh
particularly among dario argento fans
very very divided um nobody thinks it's
a great movie okay it's just i'm going
to tell you that right now i don't i
don't know a single person but i kind of
feel like
it just gets really really mixed reviews
i feel like a lot of dario people like
ah it's all right like it's not great um
but like i said i've seen some dario
argento fans that really hated it they
thought it was awful they thought the
acting was awful uh particularly ozzy
argento's acting which like i said the
acting it's not great she's very young
uh but
you know i do kind of feel like there's
still like a charm or a vulnerability to
it that kind of gives it a little bit
you know that kind of gives it a little
something something i don't love like
the main actor he's not
bad he's just like kind of bland um like
i said i'm a little bit creeped out by
the whole romance aspect because he's
obviously she's supposed to be a
teenager and he's obviously much older
than her and uh just i don't know that
just kind of like rubs me a little bit
the wrong way but like i said
it's really not all that different from
dirty dancing if you're gonna go that
way because she was supposed to be 16 as
well so i'm not going to complain about
it too much but it is a little bit weird
especially because he spends so much of
the first part of the movie like just
say she's just a kid she's just a kid
and then you know and then suddenly
they're making out and like rolling
around in bed together so you know what
i mean it's a little bit weird you know
i don't know there's like there's a lot
of stuff about this that i like it is
kind of a mess but i don't know it
really does have
kind of
i don't know just like moments of
coolness in there so i do think that if
you're into dario that it is worth
watching just
temper your expectations like don't
think that it's going i mean i liked
this much better
than something like the card player for
example this is miles better than
dracula 3d for christ's sake uh i liked
this better also than his phantom of the
opera adaptation
so it's not the worst thing he's ever
done by a long shot um and i do actually
have quite a lot of affection for it so
i was glad to like be able to rewatch it
after all this time
and
like i said it's not i didn't find it
boring it is a little convoluted the
plot but
not too hard to follow wish had been a
little bit gorier
wish brad dorf had been in it a little
bit more i kind of feel like piper
laurie sort of foamed it in she said
that she wasn't
real uh she wasn't really into it you
know what i mean and she was just kind
of thought the whole thing was silly and
so it doesn't really come through
because she's kind of a pro but you know
you could tell she wasn't taking it all
that seriously but you know it's
overall it is what it is and uh it's
still an enjoyable movie at least to me
so if you've seen it uh let me know what
you think about it in the comments if
you haven't seen it like i said i didn't
spoil the kill or anything because
giallo's that's kind of like a big deal
but it's on shutter
and vinegar syndrome just released like
a nice blu-ray of it if you'd rather go
that route but if you have shutter you
can totally watch on there they just
added it a couple weeks ago and so let
me know what you think about it in the
comments what's your favorite dario
argento movie do you love this one do
you hate this one
you know are you just not into it do you
not get it or whatever just let me know
in the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye